لقد تركت الحملة الإسرائيلية ضد حماس في غزة
الكثير من المناظر الطبيعية، حيث
أصبحت البنية التحتية للشركات والمنازل القاحلة في حالة خراب، وأصبح الكثير منهم
لاجئين دوليين نازحين داخليًا يكافحون من أجل البقاء كل يوم،
يلقي بن ويدمان، كبير مراسلي CNN الدوليين،
نظرة فاحصة، ولم يتبق الكثير لاستعادته
من منظر القمر الذي كان مدينة الزهراء
في وسط غزة، فقط بعض قصاصات الخشب التي تم
سحبها من الأنقاض، كانت الصعاب والنهايات
التي كانت في يوم من الأيام
حياة الناس لا يمكن لأحد أن يعيش هنا بعد الآن، لقد تم
تقليص الدمار الإجمالي للحياة في غزة إلى الأساسيات في عصر ما قبل الصناعة
وجود أصبح فيه الناس
يقطعون الحطب حيث يمكنهم العثور
عليه، ويجرون المياه حتى لو كانت
المياه بالكاد
صالحة للشرب. يخرج باكر كل يوم مبكرًا
لجمع الحطب الذي تستخدمه زوجته لإعداد
وجبات الطعام. تقدر الأمم المتحدة أن
حوالي 80٪ من سكان غزة  لقد تم
تهجير أكثر من مليون شخص محشورين
في المدارس التي تم تحويلها إلى ملاجئ،
نعم، احتفظ
بتقارير منظمة الصحة العالمية
أنه بدون النظافة والرعاية الصحية الكافية
والأمراض الغذائية تنتشر
زوجة بيم، وتمزق الخبز اليومي القديم
والقديم لتحويله إلى حساء رقيق مع
العدس.
لم يعد هناك مكان في هذه المدرسة الواقعة في
المعزي وسط غزة، تنام أوميدي
وعائلتها الكبيرة المكونة من أكثر من 20 فردًا في
الجزء الخلفي من شاحنة محمية من
العوامل الجوية بقماش بلاستيكي هربت من
شمال غزة ولم يكن معها سوى ما يمكنها
حمله يائسة للعثور عليه الآن.  ما يكفي من الطعام
لإطعام
أطفالها [موسيقى]
ربما يكون هذا ترحيبًا مخففًا
في
نهاية العالم الآن بن ويدمان سي إن إن
القدس